こんにちはドクター
チャーチの靴が飼いたい皆さんはたくする道がよく出ると思うんですけどもスライム
あると思いますあのすごいたのスライムを使ってイメージが強いと思うんですけども
そんなに五第六の動画だしてませんからね今日はとんでもない情報を仕入れてきました
なんかツイッターできたんですけど頼りに治療をかけて水分を抜くとスーパーボウルに
何だしてますのでぜひやってみてくださいという情報をいただきました
ああああああ
やりますとモスライブってどんなものかといいますと鍛えた答えの中華みたいなもの
代打もすぐ作れるのはスライム魅力なんですけども今回はあえてし羽生世代もゾンビし
ましたまずこちら
電球のスライムはう
[音楽]
a これができるスライムです是非こちら
スライム坊主坊主はいらないよスライブだけでいいです
ブリブリようならブリブリオナーズありませんスライムです
指や押し込むとブリブリなるよって書いてありますね下品ですね
俺劇んだの好きじゃないんですよ
はっはっは
なミルクスライム藪ないよみる具材もあぶないよ
赤ちゃんまず上でスライムどんなかもしんないからねなんであえて危ないの作ったん
続いてこちらゼリースライブ危ないよフェリーとも違って子供が食べちゃうなんで
みんなスライム食べさせたいの
どうなってんだ今日本相まってセレブを食べさせるとこれしかないや綺麗ですね素敵な
色でございます
ad あんスライムみたいななんと中にエイリアンが入っておりますは出てきた
はぁ
えっスライムは自分でスライム作らなきゃいけないんだめんどくさというわけでここに
6種類のスライムを準備しました彼の県外によるとスライムにしようかけて乾かして
水分を摂るとスーパーボウルになるかもしれない
モースこれが本当ならばここはここに阿部世代も混ぜ合わせて巨大なあのう
巨大な
スライムを作りん
[拍手]
いいのが出来たぞ share グルーうーん8ぞ
やはりこれもいいのかなぁは方ですとりあえずあの
売ってた皿やモデル混ぜてみましたぁー air
0すぎるよーすぎるけどこれが混ぜてことなんだよね
お母さんな備えがいなく仲良くしてますねとりあえず全部の船もしっかり混ぜ合わせ
ます
[音楽]
ちょうどで結構巨大な債務になりましたこんなこと凄い者いないんですけどこれで
スーパーボウルにならなかったらすごいの中
色々辛いんでとりあえずこのサイズでスーパーボウルになるか実験してみたいと思い
ますがこれでもスーパーボウルになったら相当でかいですからね
テレビの技教えをかけてゆく
ああもうセラないよつらい日に教えをかける意味たことだよ
いやでもちょっとネットのぞを信じてきます7章
めっちゃかけましたなんかやっぱジャイするなぁワークはググーっ特に現時点で反応し
ているよさはないんですね塩分過多になるくらい塩かけてみますっって埋まってまず
やばいなんかああやはりドロドロになってきました
もう
どんな水ですよ待ってだけねー
[音楽]
はいバッハ
水やあのオンラインでもう一だとこれがちゃんとスーパーいいのにも本当に水1回容器
に移しましょう
じゃあもう水すぎて大丈夫かこれ移せるからそもそも後も意外とまとまる
黒いここから成分を摂るのでハワイアンの時間です
シーンところ何年かかるんだもうちょっと詩を書かせましょう
めっちゃ削いでる間でもどうだこれで相当タバコのスライムの中になる主要の含有率が
高くなったんでさっきより確率上がったと思いますあと食べない
[音楽]
まとまらなくていっ
えっなんかめっちゃ滑稽みたいなのが出てきました
って没られなんだなんだよなにこれ何になりすぎなんか
種みたいなのが出てきた
エッグ大丈夫これ本当に一部債務だけが必要に反応したという説がありますねや提携も
その雪しかないな多分もうちょっとまとめてあったりと思います
やっぱり気持ち悪いよやこのかたまにま月も2月的排除しますマジで持つライブじゃ
ないようなたちはえっ本当にグロテスクなんだけど a にゃんじゃあもう
ブーツ中華ともっとヤバいとことに撮ったんであともうまあ今のところするセルの
スライムですどんどん乾かしていきましょう
ん書いてるね時間くらいとないしました
ちょっと硬くなってきた気もするんですけど結局まだとうとうのままですねドライし
すぎたーい
だからなくなってきましたいやーこれ本当にか若干の不安が残るんですけどもう
ちょっとをトライしてみましょう
ガバナーん
[音楽]
ん
はぁ
[音楽]
me
teal
car
ああっあああっ